Where we came from
a beautiful sky
Call Me Sire. Okay I'm pleased to be here as
i gaze out at this crowd I am reminded of my
soul purpose in the universe to take unevolved
disgusting low life scum such as yourselves
and enhance you genetically to
something less reprehensible
thank you for inspiring me with how
vomitus you all are the the bile in the
back of my throat as I look at you is all the
motivation I need to move forward and create
the perfect species thanks to High Evolutionary
I can't wait to you and see what I can learn
The high evolutionary welcome back everyone this
will be my Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer video
for the high evolutionary he's the main villain
of the movie and the clip there from Comic-Con
kind of gives you a vibe for the character
he's meant to be like the next in their line
of really bad space dads he's being played by
Chukwudi Iwuji who you probably remember
from The Peacemaker series he's going to be the
person who created rocket or turned him into the
more humanoid version of Rocket because he started
out as a regular raccoon he's also one of the most
powerful villains that Marvel has introduced
from the comics recently so I'll explain what
they've changed about his backstory and how
he's connected to all the other characters in
the MCU if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll be getting
more Marvel trailers soon because Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum media is coming out really soon and
it's the beginning of Marvel phase five like
the official beginning of phase five Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 is coming right after that one
of the big differences in Marvel Phase 5 versus
Marvel phase 4 is that they're going way more
Cosmic heading into Avengers 5 King Dynasty and
Avengers 6 Secret Wars and introducing some of the
weird order Cosmic characters Adam Warlock in the
high evolutionary are some of the best examples
of that I did a much bigger Adam Warlock video a
while ago so I'll link it in the description
below the reason why I wanted to do a high
evolutionary video is because Adam warlock's
origin is so connected to the origin of the
high evolutionary it's also one of the reasons
why James Gunn waited to introduce both of the
characters in the same time in the same movie High
evolutionary has been a big character in Marvel
history he's tied to Scarlet Witch quicksilver's
backstory but they changed that for the MCU just
a little bit they're making him more of a cosmic
character exclusively in the comics he started
out being a regular human originally his base
was in the Wonder Gore mountains this area in
the mountain range where the dark hole Temple
was in the MC where Scarlet Witch was trying
to pierce the Multiverse in the original Marvel
Comics Magneto is the father of Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch but he was hiding his powers at the
time the locals found out about it tried to kill
him and in order to protect his children he sent
his wife who was pregnant with them to the Wonder
Gore mountains who was helped by Bova one of the
create creations of high evolutionary their mother
died after the childbirth but High evolutionary
sheltered them as babies for a little while before
they went into their next adventure eventually the
high evolutionary decided to take his base from
the Wonder Gore mountains into outer space as I
said though originally he started out just being a
regular human scientist from Earth called Herbert
Edgar Wyndham there was an Easter egg for this
during Guardians of the Galaxy 2 the plants that
they crash on at the beginning of the movie was
called bur-hert an anagram of Herbert they might
change his backstory a little bit for the movies
and just say that he was originally an alien who
was humanoid from another planet but he's similar
to characters like Mr Sinister from the X-Men and
that they're both scientists who were obsessed
with Evolution thus the name High evolutionary
the only difference between him and a character
like Mr Sinister is that Mr Sinister was primarily
focused on the bloodline of Jean Gray and cyclops
in the x-gene whereas High evolutionary had
much larger Ambitions for evolving the entire
human race he was kicked out of Institutions on
Earth for his radical idea ideas and then started
wearing this armor because he'd experimented on
his own body trying to evolve himself he's super
powerful in the comics he can graft Powers
onto himself he's gone up against characters
like Galactus in the trailer it seems like he's
also experimenting with dead Celestial technology
here like this looks like the intestines of a
Celestial like the of a Celestial one of
the only big differences though is in the comics
his armor is red instead of purple like you see
here he's primarily known for the way he evolves
animals into beings like Rocket taking regular
animals giving them more humanoid characteristics
trying to create the perfect life form like giving
rocket all these other animals the ability to
speak so these weren't humans who were turned
into animals these were animals who were turned
into humanoid hybrids during the Comic-Con clip
he basically tells you what his whole thing is
I'm trying to experiment on things to create the
perfect life form one of his most famous things
in the comics was creating a place called counter
Earth this place in the trailer that looks like a
freakish version of Earth where all these humanoid
hybrids are living in the comics counter earth
existed on the other side of the Sun and in an
alternate Dimension so that it couldn't be seen
by regular humans but it was meant to be like
his version of the Garden of Eden where he could
just continue his experiments in seclusion this
is where his origin story starts to intersect with
Adam warlock's origin story The High evolutionary
was the person who gave adam Warlock the soul
gem in his forehead which Adam Warlock was very
famous for in the comics like he was a big part of
Marvel's Infinity Gauntlet storyline even though
they didn't do that in Infinity war or Avengers
end game Adam Warlock was created by a group of
villains on Earth called The Enclave in the movies
it's the Sovereign obviously from a different part
of the Galaxy and that's why he's gold colored
eventually he left that group and had Adventures
around the universe just trying to learn as much
as he could about everything he's kind of like
a version of vision born this extremely powerful
being but just trying to learn as much as he can
not knowing a whole lot being either truly bad
or truly good eventually he discovers the high
evolutionary encounter Earth and helps him take
down one of his Creations that's gone Rogue taking
over counter earth called man Beast he gives him
the soul gem as a huge power upgrade because man
Beast is so powerful while Adam Warlock is saving
everyone on counter Earth some of the people
there give him his first name Adam which was a
Biblical reference as in the biblical Adam and
Eve from the Garden of Eden because that was what
counter Earth was meant to be so there's all these
biblical metaphors during this counter Earth Saga
I'm not expecting to get super religious with the
movie version of this in the MCU but as I said in
the trailer it seems like his version of counter
Earth is actually based around the intestines of
a dead Celestial or a giant Cosmic creature like
the of a Celestial there's going to be all
kinds of jokes about that when the movie comes out
because metaphorically High evolutionary is meant
to be a giant one of the other big changes
in the comics too is they're also making him the
person who created rocket in the MCU they was an
Easter egg for that during the first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie in their big lineup like you
see Rockets number here that's the number of his
experiment that the high evolutionary gave him he
just refers to them by their experiment number
subject 89p13 calls itself rocket the result of
illegal genetic and cybernetic experiments on a
lower life form in the comics it was just a group
of random scientists called the game Masters
on a planet called half world that created him
they're just saying that the high evolutionary
controls the MCU version of half world the
otter that you see him hugging in the trailer
is his girlfriend in the comics called Lila I
think is actually going to be voiced by Daniella
melchior because James Gunn said that she had a
role in the movie but they haven't fully revealed
who she's playing what it seems like based on all
the trailer footage like you see the Guardians of
the Galaxy in prison looking uniforms that's meant
to be a parallel for the first movie they're
in this facility here that seems like it's
controlled by the high evolutionary it seems like
they're going to try and Rescue all these humanoid
hybrids experiments that he's been working on it
might have something to do with Rocket's former
girlfriend Lila contacting him asking for help
like some sort of distressed Beacon that they
detect leading them to return here because in
the trailer he says I'm done running part of
that is the idea that he's been running from the
high evolutionary this whole time he escaped and
never wanted to go back he's been trying to stay
as far away as possible this whole time but James
Gunn said that this movie more than the other
Guardians movies is all about rocket like he is
meant to be the main character of this movie but
a big part of his Arc during the Guardians of the
Galaxy movies is that he goes from being the most
selfish character to the most selfless character
he is his big Luke Skywalker Darth Vader moment
where he's like I must confront Vader in the high
evolutionary here he has to come to terms and deal
with his past trauma the way that James Gunn talks
about his origin story he says that rocket was
just totally happy being a regular raccoon he did
not want to be evolved he's actually really upset
about what happened to him even though it seems
like it would actually be pretty cool to get all
those extra powers and giving rocket the ability
to talk if you look at him it actually looks
like it was super painful and super traumatic
physically and mentally for him which is part
of the reason why in the early Guardians of
the Galaxy movies like the first and the second
one he's so salty as a character even though he
does genuinely care about the other characters
eventually they use his relationship with Groot
and then baby like the new version of Groot to
kind of show you how he's developed as a character
the way that James Gunn explained it is that
during Infinity War when everyone is being snapped
and you hear the young version of group like Baby
Groot who's now teenage Groot crying out to him
saying I am Groot in a really sad kind of way
what he was saying to Rocket was he was calling
him father like he thinks of Rocket as his father
and obviously in the MCU movie version of this we
have Adam Warlock versus the high evolutionary the
whole idea that high evolutionary wants to create
the perfect life and that's what Adam Warlock was
created to be by The Sovereign the perfect being
even though they work together in the comics they
aren't like buddy buddy or super best friends in
the comics or anything like that so I'm expecting
their relationship in the movies to be a little
more antagonistic originally in the comics Adam
Warlock was also created to be a villain and I
think that's part of his Arc during the first
movie too is that he starts out trying to kill
the Guardians of the Galaxy like that was the
whole reason why he was created eventually while
he's trying to chase them down and kill them he
crosses pass with the high evolutionary and then
that leads to him slowly realizing the Guardians
aren't that bad and probably winds up helping them
take care of the high evolutionary because I think
part of the idea is that they do want to redeem
Adam warlock's character throughout the future
MCU movies maybe not entirely during this movie
but High evolutionary will not find any kind of
redemption he just meant to be a really terrible
person like another bad Marvel dad like Peter
Quill's father ego The Living Planet like Gamora
nebula's father Thanos and that's the other reason
why James Gunn changed their backstories and made
him Rocket's father so to speak in the movie he's
like the next in James Gunn's line of bad space
dads and that's the whole thing in the Guardians
movies is it's all about bad space dads I don't
think that they're gonna kill him at the end of
the movie in the same way that they're kind of
ambiguous about what happened to Ego The Living
Planet like is he dead or is he still out there
somewhere like they're really really hard to kill
like how evolutionary is super powerful so if he
winds up coming back in a future movie how do you
want them to use high evolutionary just because he
does continue being a big character throughout
all of Marvel Comics everyone click here for my
big Guardians of the Galaxy 3 Adam Warlock video
and click here for my new Loki season 2 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!